this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the
popular online
series the table is my co-host today you
can join him on podcast or on youtube to
watch the table
listen to the table anytime in the
meantime he's here to help you
and i am too the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five amon is
with us in houston hey aman how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i wanted to ask you about the
situation i'm in so i'm deciding between
a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
or to save up and buy a home in cash so
the thing is i in my religion we have a
20 um required charity so basically
at the end of the year any money we
didn't spend from our income
20 of whatever's left over we had to
donate to charity
so if i were to save for a house i'd
have to pay a lot more in charity
which means it would you know take away
from my house savings but if i got a
mortgage
that money would be an expense so i'd
have to pay less charity and put more
towards the house
so with that 20 number what would you
recommend would i
get a mortgage or save up for a house
and pay in cash
how old are you i'm 22.
and what's your income 160 000
wow how what in the world do you do at
22 years old making
which i 160 uh i'm a software engineer
no no of course you are
yeah okay you're smart good for you way
to go
okay so what uh what are you gonna pay
for this house in cash or what are you
gonna pay for this house and how long is
it gonna take us to get there
uh i'm thinking around 300 000
and uh probably trying to save up over
the next four to five years
to pay for it cash yes how much do you
have cash right now your savings account
i have not started work yet but right
now i have about ten thousand dollars
oh so you're not working you're just
coming out of school yeah
okay so what would happen if you lived
like a college student
and did this in like three years
yeah i could do that and my expenses
would be pretty low
yeah and so the does the 20 apply
i i don't know the technicalities on on
your process
does that apply to whatever you have in
savings every year or what you added to
savings this year
what i added to savings this year okay
and so if you put in a hundred thousand
it'd be 80 the next year if you put in a
hundred thousand b 80 and the next year
if you put in a hundred thousand be
eighty and you'd have two hundred and
forty thousand
exactly okay and buy a 240 000 house at
25 years old cash
yeah but what would it make more sense
to get a mortgage which would be
cheap like what sixty thousand
particularity versus sixty thousand
in interest or less than sixty thousand
interest which could be
so what is your religion uh
i'm a a sect of islam called the shia
muslim
okay and um
i've got some friends that are muslims
that are doing some teaching on
what the koran says about money
and they're kind of building out you
know we're christians we kind of do it
from a christian perspective they're
doing it from a muslim perspective which
is very cool by the way
and uh they were teaching me that uh the
quran is
harder on debt than the bible is
yeah it is pretty tough on debt a lot of
people don't take any interest at all
actually
yeah and not only the users issue but
the whole
uh the whole debt thing in general so
i don't know i mean i i what i'm
suggesting is
maybe you're choosing which part of the
quran you're going to be worried about
here
and if you were worried about the debt
part you would get gladly give up the
other 20
i kind of like i kind of like the saving
um you know
it mathematically doesn't work but yeah
technically charity doesn't work
mathematically
in general because when you give money
away you don't have it anymore
right uh and but yeah every religion of
quality suggests generosity of some in
some methodology christians
you know orthodox jews 10 tithe uh
you've got a 20 on savings there that
you're teaching me about that i wasn't
aware of
and uh so it's not unusual at all for
some methodology for generosity to be
built in
meaning that in general most religions
believe that god says we're better off
if we're generous
right right and so i don't think there's
a downside to you being generous
me neither instead of looking at it as a
duty look at it as a
an instruction from your religion that
is to your benefit
not even just a duty it's a yeah about
to say a benefit i like that dave
when you benefit from being a generous
person that is why you are getting this
instruction
to be generous and that's true i mean we
could say that
you know as christians we certainly
believe that god is not telling us to
give money
away uh because he needs our money he's
having a good money
because it changes your heart into a
generous person and generous people are
highly attractive but if you're doing it
as an active duty
then it's you're not getting that
benefit instead if you're doing it as an
act of
instruction where i'm seeing the benefit
of my character being changed to that of
a generous person
which i suppose is what the the
you know is this version of islam that's
what the goal is
it would make sense to me that that's
how that works but dave let's take away
religion from this if i'm 22 years old
and i'm making 160 000
a year i'm staying at home and just
going to just save up and just buy a
house cash buy 25.
and even if you take away the religion
you have to stay home yeah i mean
you live on 60 grand exactly that's no
slouch no stops
at all a lot of people coming out of
college wish they made 60 grand
absolutely
so um you know that that's an okay
that's an okay version
i i still think i mean it's an
interesting discussion and i like look i
like talking about it through this lens
because i think it's instructive
but um you know so so the point is
that even though your law even though
you're down by 20
i think your character is up by more
than twenty percent your generosity
makes you more attractive you are a
better person you
on the long haul are going to prosper i
don't know that you're gonna prosper in
this calendar year
by the equivalent of your giving that
probably seldom does happen
but i will tell you that generous people
over the scope of their life
tend towards prosperity because they're
more attractive
people want to do things with them
they're the ones that smile they're the
ones that hold the door for you they're
the ones you want to promote
now this is not someone who's acting out
of religious duty though
that's not generous that's just
following the rules being a
a religious boy scout yeah and that's
that doesn't give you that benefit
but the idea that generosity should be
key in your financial plan if you are
doing it out of a compassionate loving
giving heart not a dutiful heart
i think it's a very important part of
the discussion i agree
i do so even all that aside if i could
save up and pay cash for three years
regardless of what rules i'm doing it
under
i'm done i'm doing that yes
yeah you're gonna be 25 years old not a
quarter or a hou own a home that's a
quarter of a million dollars
and you'll be making 200 000 a year
you're going to be in good shape sir oh
yeah you're going to be all right
oh yeah oh yeah i don't know
how was that age oh my gosh that was why
i say something i'm walking up
you know walking up there hell both ways
to school
i just know i just wanted no shoes if
he's single yeah you know
yeah so yeah well the ladies are lining
up they're one
they're all looking for a software
engineer right now like izzy is a
software engineer in dead gum
houston right there i'm just saying oh
my gosh way to go dude i'm so proud of
you
really cool thank you for the call and
thank you for the question
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author host of the
table
on youtube and podcast is my co-host
today
if you're tired of feeling stuck with
your money like you'll never get out of
debt you'll never save enough for the
future it doesn't have to be that way
you can make progress with your money
and you can do it really faster than you
think
the only way to make it happen is with a
budget with a plan
following the baby steps with the
instruction the support
that's why you need a ramsey plus
membership you'll get
access to financial peace university the
premium version of our every dollar
budgeting app you'll plan out
every dollar thus the name and save
before the month we spend a say before
the month begins when you budget and you
get intentional with your money
you make progress really fast and you
can start budgeting for free
today to start your free trial at ramsey
plus text
trial to 33 789 that's trial two three
three
seven eight nine open phones here at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five boaz is with us in
wichita kansas
hey boaz what's up hey dave how are you
great man how can we help hey um
i i'm currently a college student um
here in wichita and i am kind of
wondering i have about
twenty two thousand dollars in savings
and about uh two thousand dollars on my
debit card
um i'm kind of afraid because right now
i hear with all the new money being
printed
that um inflation is going to hit it so
i'm wondering
since i'm currently a college student
what did you hear about summit in them
what did you hear oh i
i i was hearing that there was like
going to be a lot of inflation maybe
here
coming since they printed off a lot of
money who told you that
oh man well that's that's the that's
what i've been hearing from a couple
people
so i'd like to know your drinking buddy
in college
[Laughter]
uh no just a little bit on uh youtube
and things like that oh
you went down a rabbit hole of
conspiracy theory crap that's what i
thought you've been playing on the
internet
getting financial advice oh dave
what year are you in uh boaz um
right now i will be becoming a sophomore
over at wichita state okay cool what's
your question man how can we help
i'm wondering if i should go and either
use that money towards
uh my college um
but currently i'll be working so i'm
wondering should i just use my money in
my savings should i just invest that
and you're saying you want to invest
because you're scared that you may
have some inflation uh issues coming up
down the road right
yeah like my my interest won't like and
my savings account won't keep up with
the inflation rate which it's not
currently
so i'm wondering if that's a smart idea
let's stick it into investments pretty
much
so let me ask you this question let's
say if you did do that let's just say i
say yep do that how are you going to pay
for college
um i was only going to stick about five
or seven grand in there
and then the rest i was just going to
work while i was in college
so here's my thing no don't invest
nothing
you have the 22 000 and 2k in your
savings account
the best investment you can make into
yourself is right now it's not into
you know investing it so you can save on
inflation no you want to make sure that
you graduate debt-free
now once you graduate debt-free and if
there is some
level of inflation then let's worry
about it then but the key thing is i
want you to graduate 100
debt free um and so keep that money in
your savings
use it to pay for all of your cash get
off of youtube or only get on youtube to
listen to the dave ramsey show
the way dave is looking to meme right
now you may want to come watch my show
first
then go come and look at dave
because dave really wants to talk to you
right now but i'm
uncle dave and i'm your nephew so uh
so uh what are you studying
um i'm studying aerospace engineering
good for you good for you
so here's the point a guy like you that
even know
has enough good common sense to even ask
this question
is so far ahead of the game studying
aerospace engineer
that you investing in you what anthony's
telling you to get that degree debt-free
is worth a lot more than any investment
that you could possibly make
no mutual fund will keep up with what
you're going to be worth because you are
getting an aerospace degree
follow me mathematically yes sir
mathematically
you are more valuable it's not that's
not some kind of
existential thing of we think boaz is
awesome although we do
but this is more like dude the money
that you can make
with that degree is greater than the
money you will make on a mutual fund
get that degree get a debt free
anthony's advice is exactly correct
okay now let's step back for a second
though just for the fun of it and have
that inflation discussion okay
just to uh just to soothe your fears yes
there's going to be some inflation we're
already seeing it
and what inflation is is an increase in
costs
the cost you have to worry about
increasing is college
you don't have to worry about the cost
of milk over the next three years
ruining your life you do have to worry
about the cost of milk or gasoline
or whatever other components of
inflation that there are ruining your
life
over 50 years but not over four years or
three years or two years while you're in
college it's the long-term drip that
where inflation kills you
the only way that inflation would kill
you in two years is if we had hyper
inflation which we have never had in the
united states
and hyperinflation is where all goods
and services
triple in one year or quadruple in one
year
so a 200 000 house becomes an 800 000
house a gallon of gas is going for 14
and a loaf of bread is ten dollars
and if you saw that then your fears
would have come true but that would be
the first time in the history of the
united states
by the way there's only two instances
that we can find in modern in the modern
world economy
that that has actually occurred one was
in pre-nazi germany and the other is
good old south america argentina
okay and so we saw collapses of the
entire economy as a result new
governments rose up
and all currency was disbanded and they
started over
this is how hitler came to power by the
way it was not on his charisma
it was an economic collapse and he
stepped into the vacuum and made himself
the hero of resetting it
and it was from hyper inflation so you
can go back study that by the way
but it's an interesting discussion the
point being is it's not going you know
if we have a five or a ten
if we normally have a four percent
inflation rate if it's
seven percent which is probably going to
be because we're seeing cars go up in
value
houses go up in value two befores are
going up plywood's going up
you know resin you name it copper steel
everything's gone up because of the
shortage because there's a you know
factories were shut down now they're
coming back after cover trying to catch
up on the supply demand curve
and we've got an artificial inflation
rate kicking up but it is a short-term
thing dude and it's not going to kill
you
with your aerospace degree you're going
to be just fine
calm down quit watching cat lasers on
youtube
i'm gonna get you jason's with us in
dallas hi jason welcome to the ramsey
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey man so i am on baby step five
and you give great advice on four and
three as far as
kind of how much to save and but our iso
five is not so good
oh man jason i feel so hurt i feel so
hurt by that
we have a number one national
best-selling book and you're saying it's
not so good
oh my lord oh no
how much how much should i should i be
putting away for a child or
or the reason the reason it's so vague
and we just say college savings at baby
step five because we don't know if you
got a 17 year old or 17 month old right
got it but jason studies are showing
from our research and from
i wrote it about this in my book that
for in-state school you need to have
about a hundred thousand dollars for
your child to go to for
to graduate within four years today
today yeah
and you can add inflation tuition
inflation
to that yeah depending on how old your
kid is
so where you want to send them to school
how much do you want how much of the
money do you want to provide
all of it or not and then you can back
into that how old are your babies
uh one is two and one is due
in seven days you are a great dad
phenomenal you are a great dad you're
ahead of the curve so what i would tell
you to do
you need a financial calculator and you
need to have a target that you're aiming
at
and your smartvestor pro can help you
with that click smart vester at
daveramsey.com
ramseysolutions.com and sit down with
them they'll be able to calculate
exactly how much you need to save
once you identify this is how much we
want to have
18 years from today for the brand new
baby
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality host
of the table
lots of interesting people come to the
table for a conversation
you can join them on anywhere good
podcasts are played and certainly his
youtube channel as well
there's some fun stuff there and uh i
will promise you this
if you watch or you listen to the table
your level of cool
will increase yeah definitely will
that's why i say come to me first get
cool then come get it
the ramsay show does not make that
guarantee nah but the table can make
that guarantee
absolutely but you know this is i'm a
walking dead joke grandpa joke no
day but we are at a table so i mean
there is a level of coolness um
on the ramsay show when i'm on here when
you're on here
and humility too yeah that's it morgan's
in jacksonville florida
hey morgan what's up hey dave how are we
doing
better than i deserve how can i help
awesome dave first of all let me just
say thanks uh thanks for taking the call
a long time listener i grew up by my dad
listening to you
ever before i could even understand what
finances were so
well i'm on i got to finally get in
thanks a financial piece baby
yes sir yes sir and i'm about 24 years
old dave
i'm debt-free never had a credit card or
a car payment
uh i bought my own used car a couple
years back and i'm currently renting a
one-bedroom apartment with my girlfriend
and my girlfriend and i are pretty
serious and
i've actually fully funded a savings
fund for an engagement ring
that i plan on purchasing in the next
few months and popping the question
probably later this year
my dad's very traditional similar to you
in the sense of he doesn't even like
that her and i live together right now
before being married
and certainly doesn't think that merging
finances before marriage is a good idea
but i'm curious because she's in the
process of pursuing a master's degree
and with that is taking out some student
loans to do so
and so i'm wondering if it would be
beneficial for me to once we do get
engaged
start paying off her student loans as a
fiance and not a husband
prior to you know actually combining our
finances when we get married
because then you know i'd be able to
save money on the loans
oh man dave um man you know
here's the thing uh morgan i i agree
with you dad i'm traditional like your
father
you know um and i don't have any kids so
but i think you already know that so we
don't have to go there here here's my
suggestion
uh because again i feel dave eyes
looking at me he's ready to say
something
uh you i'm watching you do your thing
you get so nervous
i'm just playing um here's the thing man
i would not combine
here's what i would do because i hear it
in your heart that you really that you
love your your young lady
and that you really want to help her out
and i put my business out there
right when i joined the team here dave
knows says i was engaged to an amazing
woman
and um we had some goals but what i did
not do i did not combine our finances i
actually had a savings account
that i was parking all the money on so
when we did get married
i would just cut the check and say hey
babe let's go take care of this
of something that she had so i would
recommend that same thing for you
because morgan i'm single today and
unfortunately that engagement didn't
work out and i pray that your engagement
works out i pray that you all do get
married
but i would not combine the finances of
you and your your girlfriend today
if you have a heart for that because you
are say you are saved you are single
i always go ahead and put the money in a
separate savings account and then when
y'all get married
then go ahead and combine the check
that's my suggestion for you so that way
you're protected on both sides
if something doesn't go well cool you
still have the money if something does
go well and everything goes down the way
you want it
i think that's a great impression on
your wife key word there was white
yeah yeah and that's aside
from traditional that's more just
practical
and legal than it is spiritual
or moral okay uh we can go spiritual or
moral but we don't
you know we still answer the question
through the lens that you're asking it
which is um you know it just it sets you
up now let me give you another one that
is relational and that is is that when
you start
handing money to people i don't care who
the people is
that you aren't married to um it changes
the quality
and the texture of the relationship
so i have grown i have children older
than you okay
so if i hand them ten thousand dollars
if i'm if i don't do that in a very very
distinct and clean way
it taints it colors the relationship
does that make sense
yes it does like they could feel like
they had to answer to me about where
they went on vacation then
even though i didn't say that that's in
the air
right and so it could it could
negatively
impact the quality of your engagement
if you go ahead and transfer funds from
a relational standpoint and that's apart
from the moral
or the traditional or the spiritual
element that your dad
and i would be concerned about which is
another different discussion
it's a same issue but different
discussions around it so
the practical aspect and i've seen
things worse than what happened with
anthony
here's a really weird one like people go
by houses together and they're not
married
and one of them dies in a car wreck
now your shacked-up girlfriend
owns a house with your parents
because you didn't have a will leaving
it to her and
you your assets go to your heirs
which would be your mom and dad now your
mom and dad are half owners with your
former shacked up girlfriend
you talk about awkward as crap that gets
weird very well and i've been in these
coaching sessions with
either the parents and they're going
what do we do with her do we kick her
out or
or you're with her and you're going to
they yelled at the future in-laws that
never really became the in-laws
are now being the people from hell and
you know oh my gosh it gets
it just creates all kinds of problems
yes
so just keep everything separate dude
until you're married yeah when you come
back from the honeymoon combine
everything
and talk a lot about it talk about it
you can say i got i got ten thousand
dollars over here waiting for when we
get home from the honeymoon
i got you know and we're gonna pay that
off that's what we're gonna do and you
know how's your budget going here's my
budget and show each other what's going
on
but don't combine them yeah don't
condone them
and it's going to be a little difficult
because you are you are you guys are
living together
and so there there will be a little
temptation on both sides because you're
already living whose mustard is that in
the refrigerator yeah i mean it's just a
problem but yeah
hunter is in tampa florida hey hunter
what's up
hey dave thank you guys so much for
taking my call
a long time listener i am currently on
baby step number one just finished
paying off my credit card
um and now i'm working on student loans
um
very similar situation as your previous
caller so i'm glad he called in before
me
uh but my question for you guys today is
uh i work in sales and i travel
all around and i you know i use my
personal credit card to expense
um a lot of my traveling and you know
get reimbursed for my company
my question is should i continue using
that card
specifically just for work uh to you
know to build credit and to
to be reimbursed that um and not you
know anything personal
on that card just strictly for business
or should i just put it on my debit card
and pay it off when i get paid
no credit cards on average how much are
you spending a month
um hunter uh for the expenses probably
around uh
in between 14 to 1700 a month
cool so what i would do is i would go
ahead and just put
two thousand dollars extra into your
savings account that you can just cycle
through every single month
so that way you're not you're not
touching your emergency account
and then while you're paying off the
debt you have the two thousand dollars
there that's specifically for work
and you're replacing it every time you
get your reimbursement but i would not
uh going ahead and get a credit card
because that credit card will eventually
be spent on something else
yeah here's the thing here's the let's
appreciate that i would add a further
clarification i would do it in a
separate
checking account i agree yeah open open
a work
an account for your work travel put two
thousand dollars in there before you go
any further
before you pay any extra on your other
debts right now let's get that two
thousand dollars in there once you put
it in there
obviously you're going to spend it down
and then the next month they're going to
give you the money back to put it back
so you're
you only have to prime the pump one time
does that make sense
yes sir and then you run a debit card on
that let me tell you what this will
cause you to do it's already kind of
but you kind of went just a little bit
it's going to cause you to never use
this card for anything that's not
reimbursable
or with a credit card you go well you
know it's not that big a deal
and it's not reimbursable but and so
your balance you'll get balance creep
on a credit card that you're using for
business expense reimbursement
and you'll look up you've got two
thousand dollars out on it the crap you
bought when you were on the road
because when you're traveling you get
tired you buy stupid butt stuff
can you tell i've done that that's just
you eat too much you eat poorly you spin
poorly
road is hard the road is hard
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
brian's in atlanta georgia
hey brian welcome to the ramsey show
thank you dave it's good to talk to you
you too
how can we help i'm wondering how much
money should i have set aside
for business savings before opening a
new business
hmm well
most people are not able to do a lot of
that
um what are we talking about what kind
of a business and what's the chain what
are you changing from
and to and so forth i'm looking to open
a law practice
i currently work uh in a in a government
legal position
um so the ability to uh take on clients
before leaving this job is very limited
uh just
based on ethics rules yeah so i'm
looking to open a private practice
my wife and i have we're on baby steps
456.
so i'm just looking to see so uh what
what field of uh law or what area of law
would the private practice
be aimed at looking to um
rules estate planning a little bit of
litigation that sort of thing
business formation how do you uh so a
fairly general
family practice type situation not
counting divorce okay
um correct the uh
so i'm trying my the reason i'm asking
this question i'm trying to visualize in
my head how long before you start get
some cash coming in the door what do you
think my question as well yeah what do
you i mean what do you think i mean do
you have you
are there some models that are some best
practices
that when you launch or are you going to
be able to have anything in the pipeline
ready to go even though you haven't
actually done the work yet
not much in the pipeline ready to go but
i i've
spoken with some some former law school
colleagues that
are in a similar kind of field and got
some
feelers for how to start things to do
uh advertising and you know doing
classes in local neighborhoods and
things like that
how to get the revenue model going yeah
okay so how long
i mean are they giving you into any
indication of how long it'll take you to
get some revenue coming in
um revenue a couple of months
sustainability
probably nine to 12. okay so that kind
of gives us a clue how much money we
need right
okay yeah so probably six months
okay because um you're gonna you're
gonna have nothing for three
the first three of the of the next 12.
the back three
of the next 12 you need very little
hopefully because you'll be reaching
stability and the middle six in there is
going to be kind of middle
which totals up in my mind to a total of
about six
okay are you married i am does she work
outside the home
she does can you eat on her income
um we can eat but i don't know how well
you keep the lights on okay
all right might get a little dark in
there okay yeah um what do you make now
i make uh about 69. okay
and sustainability is about 82.
she makes 82. yes okay
yeah i'm thinking you know three to six
okay is what it sounds like six would be
preferable
um and so that sounds like what 30 grand
or something right
okay yeah so three to six of my current
income
well because that's what you got to
replace correct
while you get the other revenue going
we're going to offset that zero
for the first three we're going to
offset it almost totally in the last
three
and kind of medium in the middle six is
my that's my projection based on our
discussion but i don't know what i'm
talking about i'm listening to you
okay you mean you this we're working
this through together you're following
me i'm not
i don't have like i've done this 100
times for law firms and this is what
it's going to be i haven't i'm making
this up while i'm talking to you so
but it it's logical and what you're
saying does sound like it makes sense
you've got to get enough wills
coming in estate plans coming in and
some you know some incorporations some
llc's you've got some some maybe some
lightweight litigation that'll pay early
and take it up uh take a good retainer
on the front end
some small stuff three to five thousand
dollar retainer type things like i can
visualize you doing that with your
friends relatives
and getting this thing going in with
guys that i know that are lawyers that
make sense within a
eight mile radius of here there's
probably a bazillion of them right
okay but you're gonna have to do the
work
the marketing work right that's the big
thing the the business development we
would call it i guess in that world but
it's still marketing like you said hold
the classes on wheels have a thing
a free a free night at the clubhouse and
people can come by and ask questions
about estate planning and whatever it is
you want to build up
whatever the client is you want to get
the top of the funnel and start to have
them
uh create cash i guess the other thing
you could do is just go to work for a
private law firm work there for a little
while
you can make that transition more
ethically and still have your own
clients with you
yeah especially in atlantic georgia dave
he could do that yeah there'd be a lot
of ways to do that
but that's another direction but the way
you're the way you're choosing you're
kind of just taking the leap
it's a little scary but um you know i
think you'll be fine i think you'll be
fine but just commit to the marketing
disciplines
that's very very important in this
andrew's in washington dc
andrew welcome to the ramsay show how
can anthony and i help
hi dave great to talk to you you too um
question
question about we have a a rental
property that is
it's paid for and the way the real
estate market is
now um i'm thinking it probably makes
sense to
offload that um and use that profit to
pay off our current home um we have a
current home with a 15-year
mortgage on it um so having that paid
for
sounds really nice um but but also
wondering
you know if we do that is how do you get
back into the rental
market uh or not how but like you know
when's the right time do you
do we buy another rental home in the
next few years or
um just want to make sure we are well
diversified with our
our assets if you will cool good for you
what do you make
uh we make about 300 000 joints
wonderful good for you well done how
much is your current house payment
uh current house payment is about 3 500
a month okay so here's what i did
when i was in your shoes um you know i
did i didn't sell a rental property but
i was gonna
i had a check come in and when i paid
off my house i
rounded it up and i had an automatic
draft
go into the mute go into a mutual fund
and how quickly i was able to buy rental
property
with that mutual fund from my old house
payment was
freaking amazing so what i'm doing in
your case is i'm going to round it to
five
grand up from 3 500 and i'm gonna pop
five grand a month that's 60 000 a year
that's 180
000 in three years plus what the mutual
fund increases in value so you're gonna
have 200 000 plus in there in three
years to pay cash for your next rental
okay and i'm gonna pay that guy we're
gonna sell it rental one today and pay
off the house today
all during this time you live in
washington dc with a 300 000
income and zero debt in the world it's
gonna change your freaking life it's
amazing where you're gonna be
andrew once you pay off the house with
the selling this rental property will
you have anything left over
that you can also put inside a mutual
fund
uh yes yeah we have we're contributing
monthly to the mutual funds as well as
well as for
maxing out 401ks and iras and stuff like
that as well
yeah i'd be maxing out everything
because your baby steps seven at that
point
and uh once you've maxed out everything
then i'm gonna take that one mutual fund
i just i i just used an s p 500 it
wasn't anything fancy no commission
uh and it just does what the market does
because it's a short-term thing it's not
a 10-year play it's not a 20-year play
it's a three to a five-year play and i
still do that to this day
extra cash beyond generosity and beyond
living i just throw it in there until
there's a big enough pile in there to
buy some more real estate because i
love real estate i'm real estate chunky
yeah
and and do you try to this was our first
rental property so do you try to
somewhat time the market
and wait for the market to correct yeah
i have to because i refuse to pay retail
yeah i'm not worried about the market
correcting as much as i'm looking for a
deal
and the market we're in right now there
is no such thing as a deal
right i mean you got you i don't know
who would be asleep at the wheel that
would sell me something
under retail when people are getting
multiple offers and getting 40 000 over
retail
so i'm sidelined right now i'm not
actually because i'm spending money
over here at ramsey campus like congress
building these buildings around here but
thank you i'm doing some real estate
investing over here but aside from me
actually out there
buying real estate at a deal right now i
would be sidelined and just waiting
because i can't find a bargain
yeah that's where i would be today uh
instead i'm putting in concrete and
bricks all over this dadgum 50-acre
campus here but that's okay
whole different world hey man good job
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality host of the
table
on youtube and as a podcast is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two
five anthony is with us in san diego to
start off this hour hi anthony how are
you
dave how's it going thanks for having me
on your show our pleasure sir how can we
help
so i've got a lot going on right now for
sure
i feel like i'm ready to
live in a box and get out of debt
because it's
so stressed so much stress and anxiety
all the time from for me
and my wife is like
she's on like she's learning and doing
some of the steps
but she's just like not as intense as i
am and uh
it's hard for her for me to expect that
from her with
you know ourselves that we've grown up
with and uh
so it's so i just i'm not sure how to
how to get her on the same page as me um
and uh we're like in the middle of
selling our house right now
you know to pay off debt and buying a
new place
and uh so there's just a lot going on
yeah
i'm confused as to what your question is
give me an example of what's going on
where you're struggling
sounds like you're on the same page
you're selling the house right
yeah so where is it you're not on the
same page i mean
like i could well i have you know i have
i have a kid he's a year old um
somewhere running on the same page is
like selling the truck and the fifth
wheel that we have
we have it's we have a loan for 60 000
i mean i i wish i knew about big ramsey
like a year ago before i made all these
financial decisions
uh but uh basically we bought a truck
and we bought a fifth wheel
um fifth wheel's at forty thousand
dollars
and then the trucks are on sixty
thousand dollars for loans so a hundred
thousand dollars on these two items and
you wanna sell them and she doesn't
yeah okay why does she not want to sell
them she thinks you're going to pay them
off quickly
yeah she thinks that we can it's like so
because for we're selling our house so
the only smart thing
i've ever done with my money is that
when i got here uh
in san diego i bought a house right away
uh back in 2016.
so how much are you gonna make on the
house when you sell it
i'm gonna walk away with like 165k okay
but you're gonna go buy a cheaper house
um i don't i mean
probably not oh you're gonna go rent
okay how much debt do you have
uh so i have the hundred thousand
dollars in loans
i have 73k on credit card debt and
what's your household income
um so i'm i'm in the military i make uh
like 100k a year 110
um and then we rent out a room uh
so is your wife work outside the home
uh no not right now but she wants to
pick up a job
she'll probably be making a couple
thousand dollars a month
how old are you guys 25
26 okay how did your wife
she's 27 okay okay
here's just some common sense okay for
both of you
yeah and it's not a matter of intensity
and it's not a matter of who's right or
who's wrong
when you own stuff with wheels and
motors
that totals more than half your annual
income and it goes down in value very
very quickly it is very difficult to win
financially
yeah and so you have a bunch of crap you
can't afford
even if you paid it off yeah i mean
it's just hard to convince her because
you know i get a
steady income and like yeah but your
steady income is not enough to justify a
hundred thousand dollars worth of pickup
and fifth wheel when you only make a
hundred thousand dollars
you're gonna lose twenty thousand
dollars a year on this little get up
while you're making a hundred it's going
the wrong way at a faster pace than it
needs to with your income
if you made four hundred thousand a year
you could justify this
if you paid it off quickly but you're
you know so i would not take the house
money and pay all of this off i'd take
the house money and pay off the credit
cards and i'd sell these two dad gum
things
and buy you a car with a house money or
a truck with house money that you pay
cash for
and the total of all your vehicles with
wheels and motors needs to be less than
50
000. if you want to win with money now
if you want to go around and be stupid
and normal
stupid and normal's everywhere that's
not that's a long line to get in
yeah i mean i understand that it's just
been tough for me to relay that
uh well it's a simple math thing it's
not an emotional thing
it's not a your right she's wrong thing
it's a
honey when we bought this we were stupid
we didn't have the money to do this when
you make a hundred thousand dollars and
you own a hundred thousand dollars worth
of crap that's going down in value
it's hard to get ahead
we need to undo our stupid here
this is the conversation we have at our
house yeah i was just about to say that
because i heard anthony laugh and he was
like dave you're asking me to go to my
wife and say
we were stupid i think this millennial
he was stupid yeah i was going to say
that
yes i don't care but there's lots
there's plenty of stupid to go around
here
anthony's like i'm gonna be sleeping on
the couch dad well i mean
we want to keep the dadgum trailer
that's right so we
is stupid you know we can figure this
out here but
um you know so but you can you cannot be
insulting if you don't want to be that's
fine
the point is that there's a simple math
thing going on here this is not a
i think we can afford it because we can
pay the payments thing that's what
children
say you know i'm not married okay but
this is what i was saying
i i definitely don't don't don't go to
your 27 year old and say we were stupid
i would go to her and say hey babe
here's a vision that i have for the
family that i think we're both aligned
with we want to be financially free we
want to be debt
free we want a prosperous life and right
now these two decisions that we made
that's preventing us from getting there
quicker i know you don't like this but
can you just trust me
i talked with dave i got some wisdom
they all agree that we need to sell this
and eventually one day we can get back
there but if we could do this
sell this sell the house we could be
financially
free within the next three to six months
and i think that's a good way of saying
we're stupid without saying we were
stupid
now we're saying we're smart you're just
you're just so much smoother than i am
but the uh um
so here's the thing guy the other thing
i heard you say
that's the problem here you said i'm
stressed out
yeah well that tells me that she hasn't
got a clue what's going on with the
money and she's not carrying emotionally
any of the weight of yours bad decisions
she's acting like you're her daddy not
her husband
and when she feels the weight of this go
across her shoulders
which she needs to feel because she's
like a grown-up and everything
then she's gonna see this whole thing
differently but you're trying to take
care of her and her have all of her
little girl feelings
sorry you're like a grown woman now
and grown women own up to grown men on
up to
when we do something stupid i've done
plenty stupid i made a reputation with
it
i made a living off of the fact that
i've done stupid
and tell people all the time i'm not
there's nothing no shame in that the
shame is staying in it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
well the cost of college has gotten very
real real serious money especially at a
four-year university or a private school
you need a plan if you're going to pay
for college scholarships and financial
aid
are a good plan but they should be a
bonus you need to be saving for your
kids college in an esa of 529 this is
where it's at
esa's and 529s are both places where you
can invest
after tax income and they look a lot
like
uh look a lot alike from an aerial view
the differences
age and income restrictions and the
investment options you're given you get
better understanding of which choices
are the right for you if you talk to a
expert financial advisor text invest
to 33 789 we'll connect you with one of
our vetted
smart vester pros so you can get a
trustworthy investing
guide text invest two three three
seven eight nine our question today
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best
possible deal dave this is a pretty dope
question and it comes from sean in
missouri sean says i'm 21 years old and
currently make 31
000 per year at his job i've been able
to complete some college courses
in the evening but it's challenging to
keep up with school while working full
time
i have a plan that would allow me to
work a part-time job during school
and graduate still without loans is
moving to a part-time job worth the risk
or should i keep my full-time job and
continue
with college courses part-time my
my vote is do what you got to do to
graduate debt-free
if you can do that with a part-time job
great if you have to work a full-time
job
do that the key thing is not graduating
fast
to me the key thing is graduating
without student loans
amen that will cause you uh 10 years
later to be ahead of the goobers that
are saddled with student loans around
their necks
and um so the other thing is this
the question changes shown is
depending on what you're studying
and why you're studying it if you're
getting a degree in left-handed puppetry
quit college and keep working
if you're getting a degree in
digital security then you know get
get through school as fast as you can
pay whatever price you got to do with no
debt
and get you know because you're going to
get out there and you're going to make
more money as a result of the schooling
all education is
not economically profitable
some subjects are economically
useless
so be studying something that causes
your dead gum income to go up you make
30 grand
be out there making 60 80 100 when you
come out
and then it's worth working your butt
off at the part-time job
and you know and leaning in and getting
through the school real fast but
what you're studying matters
yes and where you're going to school
matters because it's how fast you can
pay for it and pay cash for it yeah
so very very good question i agree with
you anthony that was a great
great thing so the problem
anthony and you've done so much work in
the student loan
sector and you know our borrowed future
podcast has had millions and millions
and millions of downloads now
and you're kind of the star of that show
where we talk about the epic
failure that is the student loan world
but
part of the backlash against higher ed
for going up so much in cost and against
the student loan
debacle is to say no one ever should go
to college
and we don't believe that here no not at
all not at all i believe that college is
a great route
i believe education is the best route
for all of us but
how we go about the education and where
we go to get the education
will be different depending upon
individuals some may go to community
college some may go to trade school
some may go into the workforce and get
education there some may go to a
traditional school if you want to be a
school teacher you got to go to a
traditional school route
but if you want to be a welder you can
go to welding school
and make more than the school teacher
exactly you can and so i think
one thing that i that i really want
people to understand
um i didn't finish my college degree
and there's nothing wrong with that
because my route didn't require that
but i'm still getting educated every
single day within my space
uh and so i think the key thing that i'm
telling young people and even not just
young people dave all people
is identify where you want to go and ken
coleman teaches
who is our career expert once you
identify where you want to go
then back track and see what's the best
route for you
to get there and then if it is school
then cool great
uh we'll help you get there 100 debt
free but here's the thing dave study
shows that out of three kids who go off
to college
only one of them is going to graduate
only one
so my thinking is step back and
and realize well you need to have a plan
yes
you know yes and uh you know the
the university that our kids went to i
told the story a thousand times with
denise sitting in
our oldest i went to the parent
orientation with the kid and i'm sitting
beside the freshman
and they they were all braggy they were
all jacked up they were all so happy at
the university of tennessee that they
had a
54 graduation rate i said wait a minute
if she gets a 54 on a test you're going
to call that an f right
a 54 is a failing grade bubba that's it
dave what do you mean
you're all excited you got 54 that means
46 of the people sitting in this room
one out of two is not gonna make it in
four years
yes that's true and only one
in three is gonna make it at all goes
back to what i just said won it one in
three
so i wrote i just grabbed her little
brochure and i wrote across it and big
old letters
have a freaking plan yes sir cause if
you take the classes
that are required to get the degree and
they're all available
in the four years because they always
are because you bothered to look at the
schedule and actually made it your job
to graduate and graduate on time
all three ramsey kids graduate
graduating four years because i said no
money
after four years no money you'd be on
your own
it is your job to study the little
freaking catalog
and sign up for the appropriate classes
to complete the degree
why is this hard and dave you also told
your kids and correct me if i'm wrong
that they're not going out of state
you're not paying for them to go out of
state right yeah i had one of them got
approved out of state and i said why are
you leaving the family
[Laughter]
why am i paying an extra 14 000 a year
for you to go to an
another sec school that has exactly the
same dad gum everything
wow you know because they have a pretty
town over there it's they've got big
houses over there what the crap
you're kidding me fourteen thousand
dollars a year for extra for out of
state tuition just so you march your
little butt across the state line
what is this there's absolutely no value
here in this zero
it does not increase the quality of the
education does not increase the increase
does not increase their income later
does not it's just they know the
baby wanted to go school down there and
nobody had the
backbone to say no was that a hard
conversation though because i know your
kids are saying well dad you can afford
it like was it a heart i said that's it
that's that's how kind of how it went
down i can afford it
you however my darling cannot
and so you aren't going unless because
you can't afford it
well i'll take out a loan and i said
you're a rims you think you're gonna
take out a loan
you may you may be dead but you're not
taken out alone
there's not you know so it's the thing
of here's the thing i'm
being sarcastic and bombastic but the
truth is i maintained enough influence
through various levers in the kiddo's
life to say
this is a wise choice yes sir and i'm
paying for it and we're going to go with
the wise choices and here's here
well you're controlling dadgum right i'm
controlling it's my money
yeah there's a whole new idea i get to
control where my money goes
oh by the way i love you i'm smarter
than you and older than you
and so it's a really good thing to have
some control over you yes sir
until you grow your brain in i just
wanted the parents to hear that dave
because i talked to a lot of parents
who are wusses yes and they'll go out of
their way just so their kid can go to
another state to get the exact same
degree for thirty thousand dollars more
yeah if you wanna do that you wanna
spend your money on it that's fine i'm
not
mad at you but you can't convince me
that there's any value added for the
extra money you've spent
because there's not there's not
the things we justify in the name of the
college experience
we're so stupid about education isn't
that an irony
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
tyler and lindsay are with us hey guys
how are you
good great thank you welcome good to
have you guys and where do you guys live
cookeville tennessee just down the road
awesome welcome to nashville and all the
way here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off
yes 52 100
ish very good and how long did that take
five months good for you guys way to go
and your range of income during that
time
we started around 100 000 and then we
ended around
140 ish cool what do you guys do for a
living
i'm in talent acquisition and i do
health coaching
at night and i am in finance as a
controller
ah very good good for you guys what kind
of debt was your 52 000
about 20k of car and around 30
student loans okay how long you all been
married
since september so oh just the other day
yeah
oh wow well congratulations just started
okay so you get married and you uh
obviously said as soon as we get married
we're gonna knock this out tell me the
story how did all that happen
yeah yeah so it actually started with me
first i started
three years ago four years ago um by
myself when i paid off about sixty
thousand dollars
by myself good for you i graduated
college and decided i needed to buy
four brand new off the showroom vehicles
wow who let someone do that but i
decided that's what i needed to do
got myself into a mess
found you and your book read it in like
a week
and i was like ready to go so i took the
initiative on myself i didn't have a
boyfriend or husband at the time
um and then i just went with it i
started paying off my cars
which i just had the one at the time but
i started paying all that off
and then i finally got debt free by
myself um
three years ago tyler and i met
in 2019 and immediately i was already
talking about
are you going to pay this off what do
you do like
all of those things i like her dave i
like her
she's really romantic on a date isn't it
it was um i'm sure i was pretty annoying
at first
wasn't that annoying he marriages yeah
he married me
which i remind him of that every day you
married me i didn't get the full
lectures but it was close
i just worked it into conversation that
i was debt-free and i was saving for a
house
all of that kind of thing and then it
just kind of went from there
we just started talking about it and we
were just open with each other
um he had the debt yeah that's all right
it was his car and his loan she still
married you with it but you used to but
you used to have it so yeah
it's all good here it's all good i knew
i knew that there was a better way
i just needed him to see the the light
and somehow
tyler how far into her talking about
this did you kind of go
you know i think that might work uh i
thought she was crazy for a while
probably about a month or two in i
started making my own budget
and into the marriage or into dating
into dating okay well i don't even know
if we were dating at the time
yeah i think we were so into dating okay
so about two or
two months or so okay he had his budget
i had my budget
and then we like talked about it so it
worked out really well that we were
open about that and then we knew that
whenever
we got engaged which we got engaged here
in nashville
in uh march of 2020 the weekend before
the world
shut down wow what an engagement yeah it
just worked out perfectly
um but we talked about it that our whole
engagement we knew that we were going to
start a budget together
we kind of did a fake budget if you will
um and then once we got married we
came back from our honeymoon put our
accounts together and
came on went after it yep came on and
five months later you're done just ding
ding
yeah it just seemed to work out we
thought it was going to take about a
year
and then different things just started
happening and lining up and
here we are very good so todd let me ask
you this question you meet this amazing
young lady and she says hey listen check
this out if you want to marry me pretty
much you need to be debt free or have
the mindset
what was the dif the most difficult
thing throughout that whole
journey starting three years ago and
then when y'all got married
then the last five months what would you
say would be the most difficult for you
probably not being able to spend what i
want to spend
having to keep close to the budget and
yeah actually having to talk about what
we're spending on
so i went to accountability yeah ding
ding yeah
so last year i went viral because i told
um some people you know
date on the budget so were y'all dating
on a budget yeah
yeah pretty well um we each had our own
budgets
so i didn't want to do anything that was
going to mess mine up and
at that point he didn't want to do
anything that messed his up so
it it really worked out it was a it was
a blessing for sure that's so good i
like y'all
well dating on a budget doesn't mean not
doing anything it just means doing it on
purpose
yeah but yeah they said you went viral
because you were cheap
is that what they said you know what the
viral community yeah they said well
you're just on man twitter's trolls
there's nothing on their patrols anymore
the driver date says y'all have fun
dates
a little bit of both a little bit of
both i don't like to go extravagant
so i wouldn't go drop a hundred dollars
on a meal or something like that
but we've done it since yeah you can
afford to now
now you're out of debt making 140 ding
ding come on now
all right so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you've
both had
you've had a journey together and uh
lindsay you had a journey on your own
what's the key to getting out of debt
yeah my thing by myself was just staying
on the budget
my thing in a marriage is first be on
the same page
second be on a budget and third
just know what you're going after you
can't hit the goal if you don't know
what it is
yeah i would say the teamwork and watch
where your money goes
yes it's really eye-opening to see where
your money goes yeah i do if you're not
on a budget
especially when you see the eating out
budget is like
a thousand dollars in a month what the
world what
where were we yeah
[Laughter]
yeah way to go you guys i'm so proud of
you so who are your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
um we have really good families i have a
couple really good friends that
have been trying to get me on this path
a long time
and then now that i'm on the path they
are still on my team
so i have a lot of really good friends i
think he does too
very cool good for you guys well we've
got a copy of the legacy journey
which is definitely the next chapter in
your story become extremely wealthy and
unbelievably generous
so proud of you well done also got a
copy of the total money makeover and
extra copy
that you can give away to someone and
help them on their journey get pay it
forward get it started for them
way to go you guys thank you very cool
very good stuff tyler and lindsay from
cookville 52 000
paid off in the first five months of
their marriage making
100 to 140. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it is done ladies and
gentlemen yes sir
man i'm gonna put them on my social
media yeah
i think you need to i really am because
a lot of these people that are
uh griping at you yeah um
about cheap date or whatever and all
that stuff are
people that are not eligible to be your
spouse
cool because the the point is is that
there are
a wonderful intelligent attractive
people out there
like tyler and lindsey who are have a
brain
and they're in there we're in the
singles world there for a minute and
they're out there there's real ones
i know there's a bunch of freaks in that
world too but there's a bunch of freaks
in the marriage world too
yes sir so i mean you know you're just
looking for somebody who's not normal
if you don't want to have a normal life
yeah and uh
lindsey found tyler wasn't going to be
normal and tyler already figured out
lindsay wasn't going to be normal normal
sucks i don't be normal
yes sir who wants to be normal i don't
want to be normal not me
no and the key thing he said we didn't
spend over 100
on our date now they can go do it a lot
100
where do you people i
yeah yeah okay wow
yep i've been married too long i am too
old yeah this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five seth is with us in
lincoln nebraska hi seth welcome to the
ramsay show
thanks for having me dave our pleasure
how can we help sir
so i recently accepted a promotion
through work
um is decent pay raise in my opinion
however i'm trying to decide um
if i if we should purchase a house with
the move
it's about an hour and a half away from
where we live right now and i've been
making the drive
um and it they're paying my mileage up
until the end of next week
um but should i should i purchase a home
should i run a home
we're like baby step half
as far as getting our finances and your
no money
correct well no you should not purchase
a home you're in debt you have no money
yeah go rent man
i think you should move and just rent a
house up there
are you there you're breaking up yep no
i'm here
okay so uh you're are you renting now
yeah we're currently currently running
the house for my father-in-law okay
and so you're gonna move to the other
town and rent right
yep i wouldn't be commuting an hour and
a half if that's what you're asking
that's crazy land okay but yeah you
need to move up there and rent and then
you guys need to get you guys need to
lean in now and get your debts paid off
and get yourself an emergency fund built
so you can save a down payment and buy
okay but right now how much lower now
i'm sorry
right now we're saying i have about 56
000
in debt between student loans and credit
cards and stuff
how much you owe in the cars uh
i own my car free and clear both of them
uh yeah we so when we got married
i i came into the marriage with a lot of
that myself so we've kept our finances
separate
okay sound like you had to guess on that
car thing man do you owe anything
on on the other car i don't know
anything on the vehicle
there's a loan on the wife's truck so so
yeah
let me let me help you with this you're
married
all of her debt is your debt all of your
debt is heard at
welcome to marriage
okay so yeah we have we have a loan on
one of the vehicles there we go
okay and so we have
56 we have student loan debt and we have
a truck debt
and how much is owed on her truck
uh her trucks just below seven thousand
dollars
okay so do i did i do this correctly so
you
you owe a little over sixty thousand
dollars to become debt free as a family
is that right
yes sir good and what is your household
income now with your new promotion
uh with my new promotion um it
i i don't like counting in bonuses so
it's going to put us where we were
last year without bonuses which would be
72. okay
but i count bonuses because they go into
your checking account to use to get out
of debt
so what do you anticipate your bonus to
be reasonably
uh reasonably for if i do what i'm
supposed to do which i plan
on obviously um about another ten
thousand so we'd be sitting about 80 to
83.
great okay and so what we're going to do
is we're going to sit down together
and lay out a budget together and we're
going to set a goal together
of having a debt-free household and then
we're going to build an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
those two things should take you about
24 months you should be debt free and 18
and another six to build your other but
you're on beans and rice during that
time you're not going on vacation
and you're not going out to eat and
you're on a written detailed
plan yeah and when you move seth one of
the one of the things to do on beans and
rice is to make sure that your apartment
i think in that area you should be right
around 20 do not go anything higher than
25
but i want you to look at in between 15
and 20 percent of your take
cheapest possible rent because the
cheaper your rent the faster you're out
of debt the faster you can save up and
buy yes sir
okay all right now we have a membership
called ramsey plus it puts you through
our class called financial peace
university
it signs you up for the every dollar
premium budgeting app which is the
world's best budgeting app
and uh if if the two of you will work
together and go through that whole thing
i will pay for it for a year for you to
go through it
but you have to promise me both of you
are going to work on this and you're
going to go get yourself straightened
out
because you have an opportunity here to
have a great life in front of you if you
stop
being normal yes sir
will both of you do it if i give it to
you
yes sir okay all right brother you hold
on i'll have kelly pick up and we'll get
you signed up as our
gift so guys the
um just a reminder those of you been
listening a long time know this already
but
um all of the data that we have on
people who build wealth
it almost never occurs
in a household where the spouses are not
working together
one of you dragging the other one along
simply does not is not conducive to
building wealth
as a matter of fact it's quite the
opposite it's going to continue to cause
problems in your relationship it's going
to continue to cause marriage issues
it's going to continue to cause lower
productivity at work because you're
screwed up and fighting all the time
it's going to continue everything until
you can work together to a common goal
that you both agree on and that's
whether you've been married
20 minutes 20 years or 50 years
and we both you know we have combined
goals we have combined
assets combined incomes we change our
pronouns
our we us
not hers and mine yeah changes
everything
the probability of success goes way up 1
plus 1 does not equal 2 it equals 42.
you get the synergy of two people
playing off each other pushing each
other holding each other accountable
cheering for each other lifting the
other one up when they're hurting all
the stuff that you
do in marriage when you're working in
sync and in tandem
i love it i always think two is better
than one in my opinion
yeah yeah it it it really does create
that
nelly is with us in austin texas hi
nelly welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and anthony today's a good day
it is how can we help
me and my husband became debt-free in
february of this year
a six month emergency fund good and at
the end of this month we're going
to go to puerto rico great
and it's fully funded very paid for it
love it
and the thing is is i'd like to upgrade
my samsung fund to the newest
phone which is about 1200 and what's
your household income
115. and what's the puerto rico trip
cost
we actually got a really good deal with
the vrbo
with a few other couples so we actually
are paying around a thousand dollars for
the trip
oh less than the phone okay
oh i'm sorry i said less than the phone
oh that's true
i was i was actually thinking you were
gonna tell me three or four thousand
dollars okay but you're doing you're
doing fine it's all good
you got a really good deal okay good but
we haven't paid for the experience
but it has the best camera and
i just would like to purchase it for the
course
and i just wanted your commission to
make a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars you're debt-free twelve hundred
dollars in anything
it's not a need though it's just a one
yeah but if you want it you can afford
it you want it
yeah i do want it yeah nelly you can't
wait until your
your contract is upgradable and you can
get a discount on it
actually we can trade in our phones
there's 350 dollars
to trade in okay so it goes down to what
now
about 8 15. yeah go i mean i can't tell
you what to do because i'm not your
husband but i say go get the phone
yeah me too me too but maybe
you call me up and you're in baby step 2
and you want to go to get a 1200 phone
it's just a luxury item
yeah but you make 115 000 a year you're
debt free you've paid a price to win you
saved up and pay cash for your trip
you don't have to present it as a need
though it's not really a need
and you know you don't even have to talk
about the camera it's just it's a 1200
thing we got the money and i want it
yeah and that's okay there's nothing
wrong with that you earned the right to
do that both of you did absolutely i get
one every other year dave
i think husband's still in tight wide
mode he's still stuck back in baby step
three he's scared to go back to baby
step two yeah
that's what it is that's what it is and
you can't do this every day
but i think if you can make this one
purchase i don't see a problem with that
at all
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode of the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is
a special edition of the ramsey show
where we call
on everyday millionaires to call in
if you are a millionaire you have a net
worth of 1 million
or greater regardless of how you got the
money
i want you to call in and tell us your
story i'm going to interview you
in other words we're going to talk to
wealthy people
real wealthy people
not people with a political agenda
not people who were trained by a
socialist professor on a socialist
college campus
not people who vote improperly
not your broke brother-in-law with an
opinion
not some blogger living in his mother's
basement
but real people who are have built real
wealth or inherited real wealth wherever
you got it
so we're going to ask them how they
became wealthy how much wealth they have
and learn a little bit about them
with the idea being that you then if you
have not yet attained
the level of wealth that the people
you're listening to have could possibly
do some of the things that they did
which would give you a probability of
joining their ranks
it turns out if you eat what skinny
people eat you're very likely to be
skinny
it turns out if you do what successful
people do
in 60 year old 50 year old marriages
that are happily married that you will
join them someday
if you've been married 14 times i hope
this one works for you but i'm not
reading your book on marriage
i don't want your opinion if you have a
keg
and not a six-pack i don't want you as a
as a personal
trainer i already have a keg i don't
need another one of those
i need someone to show me how to get rid
of my keg and trade it in for a six-pack
this is not hard folks find folks that
are winning
at something and emulate steal
their habits character qualities and
processes
and use them and you get to join them
this is called best practices
so we're talking to real millionaires on
everyday millionaire theme hour
now for those of you who are newly
initiated a millionaire is
not someone that makes a million dollars
a year you can make a million dollars a
year and not have a million dollar net
worth because you blow it all
a millionaire is someone who has a one
million dollar or greater net worth your
net worth is calculated only one way
there is only one kind of millionaire
you don't need to say net worth
millionaire because there is only one
kind of millionaire
a millionaire is someone who has a net
worth of a million dollars what you own
minus what you owe equals your net worth
your assets minus your liabilities
equals your net worth
jay is in tucson jay what is your net
worth
hi dave we're about at 2.2 million
awesome
break that down for me in the mix of it
is it 401 k is real estate what you do
yeah we've got our personal residence is
paid for it's worth about 650
000. we've got 401k in our current
employers
a total of about 200 000 our traditional
iras
are at about a million dollars those
came from uh
direct transfer roller coverage of our
previous 401ks
and then we've got uh roth iras at about
300 000
and then some non-retirement accounts
at 70 000. cool good for you how old are
you
58. cool and how much of this uh 2.2
million dollars did you inherit
zero zero cool and uh what has been your
average or not your average your range
of working income your household income
from worst year to best year since you
started this whole process
uh well i guess uh since i started the
process
it's been about 100 to 180 000 household
income
okay what do you do for a living i'm an
engineer
okay is that what your degree is in i
assume
yeah i have a bachelor's in mechanical
engineering and i have a
master's of science of finance cool and
what was your gpas
in my undergrad program it was about 3.0
and the master's program was 3.98 cool
very cool
how much of this 2.2 million is there
because you borrowed money to do
investing
that made you wealthy uh zero if we
hadn't borrowed any money
who had been much further ahead okay so
you made some mistakes with borrowed
money
yes yeah what was the mistakes we well
we borrowed on a 401k
to buy a rental house we we bought time
shares
uh plural on loans yeah so
yeah we made some big mistakes that we
wouldn't repeat yeah
who'd you buy your time share from
uh who didn't we buy them from we uh we
bought some
a couple of them in mexico we had four
at one time
how'd you get out of them uh well one i
was able to sell on
on uh ebay for a dollar and uh
free uh about that yeah and then the
other two i had to pay
somebody like the interactive team
although i don't think that was the
company
yeah but you paid a company to get you
out okay wow yeah
wow so that was the worst decisions
you've made financially then
all right cool good for you good for you
okay so uh what would you tell the 25
year old version of you
if they want to be you when they grow up
if you want to have 2.2 million at 58
years old
yeah i would start by getting a copy of
the total money makeover and then
following all those stuff
oh i love you man you're awesome you're
so you're a smart guy
[Laughter]
well to be honest you know i i was at 44
and i didn't know you know how i was
going to retire right we had very little
money to stay we were pretty good about
staying out of debt but
you know i was a little worried about
you know what our retirement looked like
and
and uh when i got a hold of that book it
just sort of
brought everything into focus uh it's
like having a gps on
on the trip you know i knew exactly
where to go and how to do it so
that's cool it's uh it just made all the
difference for me well i appreciate the
compliment and i'm so proud of you man
very well done i mean you you've changed
this all around in 14 years
uh which by the way is about the average
that it takes for someone to become a
millionaire in the millionaire study
that ramsay did
we found about 17 years to be the
average time from the time someone
starts being serious and it sounds like
that happened to you 14 years ago very
very well done
oh by the way folks in that study we
found the top five
vocations of millionaires it's the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in north america
over 10 000 millionaires were studied
you know what the number one vocation
engineer that's what he is you know
number three was
teacher yay
you know who was not in the top five
doctor
broke doctors are everywhere
they're like broke athletes they're
everywhere
it's like a stereotype
and there's a reason for some of these
stereotypes it's very interesting no
actually doctors came in at number six
but they just did not make the top five
but everybody thinks you know lawyers
first doctor's second
doctor paul your second nope barely made
the top five attorneys were number five
just barely squeaking in there very
interesting
so it turns out that methodical
application of a system is very
indicative
of being your everyday millionaire
interesting this is an everyday
millionaire theme hour
on the ramsey show
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaires theme hour
we're talking to real millionaires
people with a net worth of greater than
one million dollars asking about them
how they did it
what they look like where the money
comes from because there are great lies
in the land
there's mythology in our culture
people are telling you all the time that
want to control your life
and so tell you that washington is going
to supply your needs
your wants and your dreams they want to
tell you that the
little man can't get ahead and yet the
proof
is in this actual statistical data that
says the little men can't get ahead
all the wealthy people have inherited
their money almost none of them did
statistically
93 percent of america's millionaires
are not millionaires because of
inherited money
based on the largest study of
millionaires ever done airtight research
the research methodology on this study
is airtight
by the way a thousand people studied
would be would be statistically
significant there are only fifteen
million millionaires
to study ten thousand of them is unheard
of but we did that to shut up
the left-wing liberal critics
who want to say that government and
socialism is where prosperity comes from
it does not come from there
it comes from the sweat of your brow and
your personal habits and your character
and your steadiness and your processes
that you use to build wealth that's
where wealth comes from
that's where prosperity comes from still
after all these years it's still true
greg is in philadelphia hi greg welcome
to the
everyday millionaire theme hour what's
your net worth
hey dave anthony great to talk to you
guys thanks for having me on
sure it's 1.2
1.2 million all right and break that
down for me give me some categories and
some amounts
so uh 650 is in uh 401ks
and uh about 450 in house equity
um we're still paying off the mortgage
so that should be done in about a year
and a half two years
okay and that gets me to 1.1
and then you got about another 100 and
something else we got another 100 and
emergency fund cash and other retirement
savings
got it okay cool how old are you
39 39 young millionaire good for you
and what was your best working year
household income and your worst
working year household income
so the lowest was right when i graduated
college it was uh
about 25 000 you know when i was 23.
uh and our best year is about 300
000. cool what do you do for a living
i'm an insurance underwriter
and my wife is a research scientist okay
very cool all right and how much of the
1.2 million did you inherit
zero okay but yeah i had help
from my parents with you know student
loans and things which was
awesome but i didn't inherit anything
okay
all right and uh your degree was in what
uh my degree was in psychology actually
okay
and what was your gpa
it was about a 3 6 if i remember
correctly it was
a long time ago very cool very cool how
many non-fiction books do you read in a
year
uh i read a few non-fiction books a year
i i read
at least a fiction book a month
okay very cool i love it i love it so
what was the biggest mistake with money
that you've made
overcome and still become a millionaire
well i think leasing cars at a younger
age was was a kind of a financial
pitfall for
for us for that income you know having
having
two lease car payments to have to pay
really
you know it was it was a strap that i
didn't you know i didn't fully
understand and
now you know i've been on you know kind
of on your program for
seriously for five years or so i've been
listening to you every day since i was
26. you think a 23 year old listening to
you and me right now can still be a
millionaire by the time they're 40.
yeah for sure yeah i would say you know
with hard work kind of sacrifice on the
front end
you're starting when you're young um
living below your knees and and staying
out of debt that that's
the main part here yeah has used all
your income
to live and build wealth
yeah for the most part yet for the past
five years and i've noticed that that's
one of the things really changed was
you know when we we started to really
focus on
you know each step at a time baby steps
so you're a baby step millionaire
excellent very cool good job man thanks
for calling in i'm proud of you good
work
mark is in denver mark what's your net
worth
1.15 million good for you break that
down for me by category
we've got 325 000 equity in our home
600 000 in retirement accounts i've got
160 000
in business equity that i'm a partner in
30 000 emergency fund 35 000 college
and about 25 000 and paid for vehicles
excellent how old are you i am my wife
and i were both 44.
oh god another young millionaire good
for you what was your
worst household income year and best
household
income year since you started we both
started from the absolute bottom
at somewhere 25 30
and worked our way up from there our
average income the last couple years has
been i think about 150 a year
this last year we made 240. wow good for
you what do you do for a living
i am in construction management and my
wife is an environmental scientist
cool and how much of this 1.1 did you
inherit
we inherited seven thousand dollars okay
so it's safe to say you're not a
millionaire because of inheritance okay
cool
and you have a four-year degree i have a
four-year degree
and an mba okay cool and your four your
degrees in what
my four-year degree is in philosophy
okay then when then you went got an mba
good what was your gpa on the mba
on the nba it was it was quite high i
loved the program it was probably 3.7
3.8
okay very good good for you good for you
so what do you attribute the fact that
you became a millionaire before you're
50 when you hear on the news every day
that it can't be done in america
days 11 years ago i was completely
broke and desperate hopeless and
really worried about my future single
dad
right about then somebody gifted me your
class
and from that point i got a plan i
married a great spouse
and we were exactly on the same page
turned off the news got organized
set goals became really generous
and just and just went at it and uh
can't believe how fast we accomplished
all this
you know from where we started yeah you
did it quick that's amazing i'm proud of
you so you're a baby steps millionaire
very good okay you sure are so tell me
about the generosity piece how does that
play in
well we give 10 either to our church or
to
other causes that we support every month
and and that's one of just the great
joys of everything we do
um we're a foster family so we give a
lot of our time and our energy in our
home
and as soon as we pay off the mortgage
uh we're set to
increase our giving quite a bit yeah
that'll change everything again
yeah and your wealth your wealth will
double pretty quickly then too
yeah i'm so proud of you guys man well
done hero
the class was a life changer for us and
just being on the same page we've been
married for eight years
and just being on the same page and
doing what you guys teach
is what and just working real hard got
us there well i'm so proud of you man
you did it
way all done well done i'm glad that we
had a small part in showing you how to
get there but you're the one who walked
the road
good stuff the average millionaire pays
off their home in 11.2 years
the average millionaire takes about 17
years to get there
93 percent of millionaires as i told you
earlier
are not millionaires because they
inherited money now a few of them did
inherit money but mathematically it did
not cause them to become millionaires
like he got seven thousand dollars
97 percent of millionaires when surveyed
say
that they believe they control their own
destiny
when the public is interviewed that are
not millionaires only 69
believe they control their own destiny
turns out henry ford was right if you
think you can or you think you can't
you'd be right
[Music]
everyday millionaire theme hour here on
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
all millionaires inherited their money
and false all wealthy people are crooked
and false
all wealthy people are famous people
they're rock stars
country music stars actors or
professional athletes
and less than one percent of
millionaires fall into that category
all wealthy people are brilliant they
have 4.2
gpas
average gpa of a millionaire is right
around 3.0 in their four-year degree
i got a 2.97
i'm still pissed about that 3 100 of a
point
probably beer involved but
no one is ever in my working lifetime
i'm 60 years old now ask me what my gpa
was in regards to whether i got to get
money or not from them
they only cared if i could add value to
their life
they only cared if i could help their
company if i was working for them
they only cared if i had good common
sense and critical thinking skills
it does not require
unbelievable almost unnatural brilliance
to build wealth in america today
it doesn't hurt so if you may if you got
a 4.2 i'm not mad at you
but most of us that are millionaires or
multi-millionaires
had right around a 3.0 we were not
inordinately
brilliant now we weren't a 1.2
either i mean i had one relative who
graduated from college after two
semesters with a degree in beer pong
they got flunked out
i mean this is not smart so you know
you do need to study you do need to
actually apply yourself you do need to
acquire academic and intellectual skills
along the way and critical thinking
skills meaning you can think for
yourself you don't need
fouchy telling you how to think
you learn to do math which they don't
teach in med school we learned during
the pandemic
so you learn to think outside
the box because the box is where normal
people live
these are the people who build wealth in
america today and they really do do it
it's not a false dream it's not
positive thinking and i'm not some kind
of baby boomer bootstrapper who doesn't
know what it's like in the real world
honey i'm so stupid i had to do it twice
i went broke after i became a
millionaire the first time
because i borrowed two dadgum much money
i got a phd in dumb
that's my degree
this time i built our wealth we don't
borrow money
we don't borrow money and you don't have
any payments
and you pay attention to where your
money's going you end up with some
this is really not a deep formula
but you don't need to get rich on
gamestop or
amc stock you don't need to get rich in
bitcoin
you don't need to get rich in gold bars
because almost no one does
statistically get rich quick doesn't
work
statistically among the millionaires the
number of them that
got rich quick and easy was very very
small
turns out that god is not in the
microwave business
he prefers crockpots he who hastens to
be rich will not go
unpunished this is how wealth is really
built in the real world boys and girls
now i know it doesn't work on cnn
but very few things do
including their ratings so here's the
thing guys
you really need to look and say what are
real people doing who have
really built wealth how do they operate
their lives how do they think
how do they treat their spouses what
kind of character these people have
because it you know really a lack of
integrity is actually a
a huge statistical indicator that you're
not going to build wealth
because people don't want to work with
crux duh
now it does happen crooks become wealthy
but that's not normal it doesn't
normally happen
normal is steadiness consistency
these are the things that was caused
people to build wealth
kathy is with us kathy is in topeka
kansas kathy what is your net worth
hi dave it's such a pleasure to talk to
you our net worth is
1.4 1.4 million good for you give me a
little breakdown on that by category
well thanks to the housing market our
house is about
400 the rest is
just retirement 401ks
iras cash so you got a million dollars
in what mutual funds in retirement
yes good for you how old are you yep
um i'm 49 and my husband husband's 49.
good not even 50 in your millionaires
love it
how much of the 1.4 million did you
inherit
absolutely nothing zero okay
zero all right cool and uh what was your
all's best
household income year and worst
household income year
since you started adult life um
well before we were married um you know
starting out
probably 24 000 our best
um about 280. good for you what do you
guys do for a living
we both work in i.t my husband is
actually a director
and and i work more on the business side
but in the i.t
department very cool good for you before
your degrees in that or in something
else
no i actually went to a technical
college
and my husband who is an i.t but
actually majored in radio and
tv okay broadcasting okay cool
and uh what was your gpa's
um mine i have no idea probably
wasn't that great maybe three of that
my husband was 3.4 good good for you
okay do you think this can still be done
the younger version of you that's
listening
oh yeah yes definitely
what would you tell them they need to do
well
i actually um when i'm i've been in
for the at the same company for 31 years
and i actually started in contributing
to my 401k
right off the bat so i would say do that
but stay out of debt i actually did stay
out of debt
as far as uh credit card but you know i
was just
normal and had the the um vehicle
loan and the mortgage and all of that
stuff and my husband had
student loans so and i should say that
we're both
um we were divorced from
a previous marriage so we pretty much
started over
14 years ago ah so you did in 14 years
yes good for you so starting over at uh
30 30 years old or 35 years yeah about
30
but yep 35. 35 years so if a 35 year old
newly divorced person is listening and
has started over with nothing this
should give them hope
yes for sure you just have to
i mean the main thing is just don't
worry about what other people
do what other people think you know
everybody's out
buying new cars every year and you know
the designer jeans
and the latest fashions and you just
have to say i don't care
you just be your own person yeah
i'm not setting my standards based on
other people i don't want to be like
them
good for you guys i'm so proud of you
what was the biggest mistake you ever
made with money in your whole life
um i i didn't
i don't know what it would be what about
your husband what's the biggest
what's the dumbest thing he ever did do
you have a dumbest thing he's right here
here i'll let you talk to him
hi mr ramsey hey i was asking her a hard
question what's the dumbest thing you
ever did with money
oh dumbest thing i ever did with money
well dave i i did the whole dot com
boom thing uh back in the late 90s
so uh there was a lot of playing with
money back then so
it went from insta range to insta-stupid
to
insta-nothing
yeah i bet there's a whole bunch of
people listening that lost their butts
in the dot-com
bubble oh my gosh we were betting on
companies that didn't even have a
revenue stream oh
kind of like some people are doing right
now oh my gosh that's beautiful man
thank you i'm so proud of you guys your
heroes very very well done
this is an everyday millionaire theme
hour here on the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 3 27 john
answered and said a man can receive
nothing except it be given him from
heaven
c.s lewis said hardships often prepare
ordinary people for
extraordinary destiny
this is an everyday millionaire theme
hour we've talked to everyday
millionaires some of which were babystep
millionaires meaning they
followed our path to become millionaires
starting from nothing
a lot of them did it in 14 years today
today we've had an engineer an insurance
underwriter
a construction manager and an i.t
specialist
that's who we've talked to so far
michael is in dallas michael what's your
net worth
uh 1.33 million 1.33 give me a breakdown
on that
by category okay about
1 million 41 000 is in our 401k
okay uh stocks and mutual funds and the
other 300 is in the home we live in
gotcha cool how old are you 51
and my wife is 48. awesome and how much
of this did you inherit
not a penny not a penny okay and what
was your best year working
household income and your worst year
working household income
uh 39 what i started my career at and
156 9. cool what do you guys do for a
living
i'm an engineer i'm a mechanical and my
wife is a homemaker she works part-time
sometimes
cool and so you obviously had an
engineering degree
yes and your gpa 3.4
cool can this still be done if
somebody's 25 years old and listening to
you
i'm amazed just looking at it this
morning i can't believe it's growing
that big
it seemed like it happened overnight now
you just steadily invested in your 401ks
almost all of it right that and got your
house paid off
yeah well we owe it to 8000 our house
we're close to being done with the house
but not quite
okay we'll be done another two months of
the house gotcha very cool
okay what's the dumbest thing you ever
did with money
your wife and i talked about this i
think we had too small of a house
payment for too many years
refinanced to a lower rate 30 years
before i started listening to you and we
should have never done that it was only
in the last about five years we've
gotten
pretty intense about panel's house ah
okay by too low of payment you mean you
just
paid as little as you could instead of
paying extra and getting knocked out
i see what yeah we did 30 years and made
it as low as we could and that's a
mistake we should have paid more
yeah you did great man i'm proud of you
very very well done
all right uh janie and john are
with us from cincinnati hi guys uh
what's your net worth
hello dave it's uh 1.2 good for you and
give me a little breakdown by category
on that
well just in quick summary we've got
just under 1 million
in retirement accounts uh both 401ks
roth iras and taxable mutual funds
as well as some uh cash sorry i'm a
little bit nervous
that's okay this is a bit this is a big
deal for us so we're excited to the nerf
at the same time but uh
i understand and then we have a paid for
home
and um it's more of a small business
it's worth a couple hundred grand uh
maybe like 130 140.
okay cool and we have some business
assets
uh some cash in my ever-growing small
llc good for you and uh some uh
software and computer equipment and
things like that okay cool how old are
you guys
jamie um i just turned 50 this year
last year december and i'm 55.
good for you guys and how much of this
1.2 did you guys inherit
not a penny zero zero okay blood sweat
and um
fpu tears
oh i love it and what was your best year
of how what was your best
more than we care to admit we you've
been in our life for for a decade now
almost on a daily basis so uh it's been
fun yeah well i'm honored
so what was your best household year
income and your worst household year
income what since you've been working
when we well when we work i mean i've
been working since i was 14 so i'll
throw the first
couple of decades out but when jane and
i got married in 2011 we were
probably just around 100 000 together
and uh our our best year was probably
200.
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a registered nurse and i'm a
machinist by trade
turned into a contract cnc programmer ah
good for you okay either obviously
jenny's got a four-year degree or more
in nursing and do you have a four-year
degree
john i do not i would like to say just a
machinist by trade and
when uh yeah high school diploma and
when when covet hit
my company of seven years laid me off
and when you're a millionaire with no
debt i thanked them for the walking
papers
and started my llc and i haven't missed
a day since yeah make more money than
you ever made in your life now that'd be
the best
best thing ever happened to you you got
fired from that stinking job
i got fired from my job and i i thanked
them and and
and i the hr lady when i thanked them
she
had this silence on the other end of the
phone i said you just made this
life dream a lot easier so thank you
very much and best of luck to you
wow way to go you're a nice guy i love
it
very cool so do you think someone
listening to us is 25 can do this
oh yes golly in fact
on on that note we've you know entered
the give like no one else
and um came across um
fulfilling the idea through your
curriculum opportunities
we had a little money to tithe and and
decided you know let's spin it somewhere
new and came across your curriculum
opportunities to purchase for different
schools oh for the high school
curriculum
and have more than it doesn't take them
as long as it took us to figure this
out so you're the way the way you're
give the way you're being generous is to
buy the high school curriculum for your
local high schools
that's so cool thank you yeah thank you
so much
yeah very nice well you guys are
absolute heroes i am so
very proud of you very well done what a
wonderful story
okay our net worths today folks were 2.2
1.2 1.1 1.4 1.3
1.2 none of these people were 10
millionaires
none of them were even 5 millionaires
all of them were between
1 and 3 million dollars in net worth
they were 30
9 50 44 49
51 50 and 52 they were not 80
and they were not 26.
the range was from 39 to 55
the average time today was 14 years
some people did it in nine or ten some
people did it in 17
there was a lot of people woke up in
their 30s and by the time they were
50 they were millionaires because they
applied the baby steps that we
teach and that's not to say that baby
steps the only way to get there but
their baby steps millionaires they
started from nothing
oh by the way the number of people that
became a millionaire that called in
today due to inheritance was
precisely zero which is
statistically accurate as well because
our study found as i've told you before
93 of america's millionaires according
to the largest study i'll say it over
and over again so you can tell your
friends who are stupid
93 percent of america's millionaires
according to airtight research in the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in north america are not millionaires
because of inherited money
why is that such an important statistic
because the lefties are lying to you
and saying that the only way to become a
millionaire is because rich people have
all the money hoarded and you can't have
any
and that is a lie that is a lie
the data says it's a lie it's not a
philosophical
moral thing it's a data thing it
simply isn't true
why does that matter because i don't
want you to have your hopes stolen
by lies that are politically motivated
your hope of building wealth and
prosperity in this country today
if you take control of your freaking
life is real
it's real it's real
it's how it's done most often
this is the message of this whole
everyday
baby steps millionaire movement they're
everywhere people
they're all around you i see
rich people
i love it oh what a great hour that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you